all right Eugene yes Eugene uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally I'm from Seaside California
tell me about your family
um well I have a
at the time
Three Sisters two older one younger
and myself
and then along uh during my
incarceration my mom had a little boy
which is my little brother Junior
who died in a house fire with two of my
nephews and
January of
2015. I'm sorry yeah
how would you describe your childhood
I would describe my childhood as Rocky
um you know not having any brothers to
look up to you know my I was like
ostracized because you know I'm a boy so
I didn't do what the girls did my
sisters did was your dad around
not not constantly I knew his face knew
who he was knew where he lived but it
were my uncles my mom's brothers who
were around more often than not and I
don't recall them ever being out of
prison or Y.A or the Boys Ranch all at
one time it was always you know it was
almost like they rotated in and out of
my life so in the prison right prison
Boys Ranch whatever and wherever they
were at at the age they were at you know
those ranches the prison for teenagers
right basically right
under 18.
so I was in the everything that I was
taught I was taught by them as far as
you know being slid liquor sucker don't
be no punk don't be weak
you know um hiding 20 gauges under my
matches don't tell your mom those type
of things you know just things that I
kind of idolized I was like okay this is
this is this is what a boy is supposed
to do this is a boy following men this
is how I'm supposed to uh live my life
these are the things I'm supposed to
look forward to those are your role
models absolutely
and you got yourself in trouble
I got myself and so but yeah yes I did
yeah what age what age did that start
that started it I think I was about
13 when I got arrested the first time
for stealing a bike
crazy thing right because I was such a
good kid I wasn't really in the
I didn't know nothing about stealing and
all that I ended up going to a group
home and I was when I was young and then
that group home we met a family uh
siblings they were all girls though my
sister's age you know so we ended up
hanging out with them going to the Swim
Center and they were stealing at a
7-Eleven first time I stole something I
had so many packages of now laters
around my socks because I was like well
this is what it is like okay that's cool
let me let me get as much candy as I can
get because I don't want to ask nobody
for no candy so you know I remember our
stuff now letters around my socks both
of my legs and as I was walking out the
store the lady was just standing there
waiting for me she was like you come
here I was like what she was like you
still I was like no I didn't and she
just started pulling up my pants leg and
I was like
you know it was embarrassing but at the
same time
because of the things that I was being
taught
is it's okay to steal if you don't get
caught I got caught because I did
something wrong so then in turn I had to
figure out okay how can I be Slicker
what do I need to do next time so I
don't get caught that mentality you know
so it went from that from the again from
the now let us to still in a bike and I
stole the bike because my mom bought me
a bike granted it wasn't a brand new
bike but it was a nice little red
Mongoose bike
somebody stole my bike three days later
can you imagine that like I was I think
I was about 11 years old and somebody
stole my bike man I was hurt
so I was like you know when I find me a
bike I'm gonna steal me a bike
you know and that's what I did
I ended up going to juvenile hall for
I don't know I think it was like three
days
but damn them three days seemed like
forever
they did it seemed like forever and then
everybody was in there was just like
Rowdy and turned up you know like
active like like they wanted to fight
like they was just full of this energy
this Untamed energy you know what I mean
and looking back that's what it was it
was just Untamed energy just bouncing
off the walls doing whatever they wanted
to do and I was afraid I was scared I
was like damn this this is what it's
like but then you know again having
these uncles these role models in and
out of my life you know punching on me
making me chub stop crying you know
things like that you know those are the
things that that started to shape my
reality you know and and again uh
created this character you know this
this character that you know uh I can
take what I want it's all good as long
as I don't get caught you know what I
mean
um
I could be who I want who gonna stop me
so yeah man just you know having a
troubled childhood man I remember
talking to my cousin he's from Oakland
the Bay Area and I remember one time
they came to stay with us and we was
outside and I was like man what's wrong
with your shoes you got holes in your
shoes and this is how far I've gotten
right this is how far I've gotten in my
criminal
thinking my way of thinking man you got
hoes in your shoes he was like I know I
was like come on let's go man we were
down there yeah we went to Kmart
absolutely came out yeah we went to
Kmart and I was like here put these on
it's like how them feels like they feel
good I was like let's go and we walked
out
you know so I tainted his life you know
what I mean because my life was tainted
not knowing no better when God we finna
find a way to go get it you think you
had a dad who maybe wasn't
you know around the streets that might
have changed your
your life if my father was present if
your dad was in your life every day
um at the time my father was addicted to
drugs
so
I think honestly
looking back I think I would have sold
more drugs honestly I think at that time
but if your dad if you had a different
dad who was not a
if my father before he was addicted to
drugs oh absolutely yeah absolutely I
would have had a different life because
and the strangest thing to say is you
know and the most honest thing to say is
there was there were there was really
only two things I ever really wanted to
do when I was young I'm talking about 12
13 14 15. there was only two things I
wanted to do and I was play football and
take karate that was it but I couldn't
do it the finances weren't right father
was absent made a million and one
promises but yeah you know uh
that's life man you know I had to I had
to grow out of that you know but I
didn't grow out of that no time soon it
took
even during my
my young years of uh like I I the last
time prior to me going to
committing the offense of going to
prison and spending 26 years eight
months in prison for a uh
home invasion murder robbery I uh I
stole a car nice car too it was when it
was a it was a this was a 1990 and it
was a 1989 Ford Escort brand new right
off the lot
and uh
man
my my homie was driving he almost ran a
dude over so the police pulled us over
you know
I wasn't driving my home was driving
they pulled us out to Cuff us up I end
up running I got away but then somehow
someway I was in the kitchen drinking a
glass of milk and it was almost like a
milk commercial I heard the female
police upstairs in the window because I
used to drink milk and sugar you know I
don't know why but I liked the taste it
was like like a cold milkshake to me
because I'd make it put some sugar in it
and put it in the freezer so when I got
home at whatever point in time I did it
would be right there just delicious so I
remember being home and I was so thirsty
because I I ran from the police I mean
like literally miles and got away
backtracking I hear them on the radio
here the cars screeching and everything
and uh I remember getting in the house
and I'm drinking my milk over the sink
because I'm so thirsty I don't want it
to spill dribble down all onto the floor
and everything so I'm leaning over the
sink and our kitchen window foam is wide
open not as far as the window but the
curtains were open and I just see this
lady I see her head poop up and she says
I see him he's in the kitchen drinking
milk and and to this day it just reminds
me like man that would be a very cold
milk commercial right there you know but
then yeah so I knew at that point that
that I was I was caught man so I ended
up going upstairs telling my mom what
happened
you know she was like all right it's
gonna put you on the bus I was like
police outside it ain't gonna matter you
know so I ended up going to the Boys
Ranch didn't do too good up in there end
up getting into a couple of fights
you know uh I was all right though I was
all right until one of my childhood
friends showed up you know and and I'm
just relaxing and somebody comes up to
the to the uh not the dorm but it was
like cabins it was in Shasta and um they
come up to me hey man your home is out
there fighting so I'll go outside that's
a big dude you know he pushed the big
dude to him like hey man don't don't
bump into me no more you see you know
what it was you know what I mean so he
pushed him into me again and you know I
knocked him out
um crazy I I that that added to my Alter
Ego though
because you know I'm a writing and I
knocked him out with my left and it's
like oh I'm feeling like oh I anybody
can get their business I was fighting
grown men at 16 17. grown men thinking
that you know what I'm a minor so if we
was to get caught I wouldn't be the one
go to jail wrong because I ended up
getting into a fight with an adult male
pulled over we throw hands and I ended
up getting arrested and going to juvie
so
I'm saying all that to say like that
just created and added on to that
monster you know that that altered I end
up spending I don't know like nine
months in juvenile hall and and then
going out to the to the Boys Ranch and
then I ended up getting kicked out of
the Boys Ranch because of the fighting
and then I ended up becoming uh awarded
this state my mom ended up telling them
hey we're going to New Orleans I'm going
to take my son to New Orleans and I did
I ended up going to New Orleans for a
while but I ended up coming right back
home sick
and uh I started doing music
and so my auntie she had a music
connection out in out here in L.A so I
came down did a show for the record
producers they was like oh yeah we like
you we like it we're gonna get in
contact with you
I waited it was like about about two
weeks but them two weeks seemed like
forever
no word nothing I ended up getting a
call from a friend hey man I got a lick
like what you talking about because he's
been doing legs it's supposed to be all
good
so we ended up going to do a lick and
that's the leg that ended up changing my
life forever
so I tell them well what's what's in the
lid how much is it how much we gonna get
he was like well it's about 50 000 up in
there you're gonna get 15. all you got
to do is just make sure don't nobody
pull up don't nobody come around what
say less I'm I'm with that like I'm with
that ain't nobody supposed to be home
either he ran down the whole script to
me and I trusted him because why because
he's been successful this is what he
does you know what I mean this is what
he does it's never been my thing and uh
when I got older my uncle told me like
you know stealing you above that I'm
above stealing so I thought like you
know jacking and Robin that was
something a little different you know so
anyway I ended up going on this lick
robbery uh people started calling it
flocking when I was in prison uh but
with three other people three other men
and a female
who was a getaway driver
she's a deceased now due to coven
unfortunately uh but we ended up going
into this house
it was like two in the morning window
going into this house
lurking around
garage door was open
so that just made it a little more
easier it made me feel a little more
comfortable about the fact that he know
what he talking about you know uh once
we get in there one of my co-defendants
reached over takes the phone off the
hook the phone blurs
y'all looking like what the hell no
you know anyway
boom this is when we find out somebody's
in the house somebody a lady calls out
to her daughter such and such is that
you
nothing
song
like this I believe they
reports the police report said it lasted
45 minutes it felt like it was a whole
day
it's not like it was a whole day it was
nothing that I've ever done before
um during the commission of this of this
uh home invasion
um I stayed in the front of the house
you know keep an eye out making sure
nobody came my Cody finish went to the
back
um allegedly as I would say because I
wasn't there so allegedly according to
police reports and according to what
I've been told
um you know one of my co-defendants took
the daughter out of the room who the the
mother was calling out for
two of my other Cody finished went into
the master bedroom put both of the
parents on the floor
man and woman demanding to know where
the safe was
the gentleman kept saying he didn't know
what his safe was
allegedly my co-defendant one of them
had his had their foot on on the the
wife's back the mother of the daughter
and the other one was dragging the other
the parent around the house the father
during that time he ended up in that
closet and called me hey come here like
what's good what's happening what's
going on with the money at you know
because that's what I was there for but
never hurt nobody see nobody what
nobody's supposed to be there had I
thought had I known somebody was going
to be there I wouldn't have went in
hindsight
if I had to do it all over again
at that age I would have done it because
of my thinking but with the knowledge
and understanding that I have today I
would not have done it so moving forward
one of my co-defense allegedly started
to threaten
to kill
the um the daughter you know he's
sexually assaulted her with the shotgun
said he was going to blow her head off
the father stood up went to do what he
was supposed to do I respected
wholeheartedly this man also became my
hero for for reasons that some people
may not even be able to conceive
but when you walk through the fire and
you sit in the fire and you become a
changed person inside and out then you
start to understand so this man was he
was a father he was a father he was
protecting his family so in the midst of
him getting up to protect his family one
of my other co-defendants went over
there to try to help
this guy
who had the shotgun to get
him into a safe zone so to speak because
he was having problems with the father
he was having problems struggling over
the gun so allegedly my co-defendant
went over there
I believe struck him in the back of the
head didn't do nothing then pushed him
down and as he fell as they all fell to
the ground the gun went off they shot
him in his lower back severed his spine
and he died
I ended up we ended up
fleeing the residents
my co-defendant the female the driver
she left us
so we're running through weeds yay high
sticks and everything like Pokey sticks
you know them sticks that poke you be
running through all kind of Madness like
in the dark no I ain't never been out
there before in my life I don't know
where we're going but I know that we
running down this road that's kind of
like you know you see the you see the
side road going this way so we just
running through the forest through the
trees do the swamp and it was swamp
uh man it was it was a it was a crazy
chain of events just everything that
happened at night because it happened so
fast but then it happened so slow
because it's like time slowed down you
understand what I'm saying it's like
man to recall is like
the adrenaline was was pumping
in me so fast and so hard that man I'm
in pitch dark we're jumping over barbed
wire fences like getting out because we
can hear the police going by see them
shining the lights and our whole thing
is just get away it took us I don't know
maybe looking back probably was about a
mile to get to my Cody Phoenix House got
over there
that was crazy
why because her father was a a
corrections officer so
my friend dated
that was his girl
so anyway
while we're in the house
two of my co-defendants are in the
bathroom because they hear him come in
so they go step in the bathroom I'm
sitting on the chair my other Cody
finish sitting on the bed this girl just
standing up trying to figure out why our
father's coming into the room of course
he's coming in the room because he hear
a whole bunch of noise what noise does
he hear well here's one of my Cody
Spinners banging on the door because he
was too slow to keep up
ironic right so
when he comes in the house he's making
all this noise breathing heavy asking
why y'all leave me why y'all leave me it
was like every man for himself what do
you mean you know what I mean like
things transpired that [__] not even
even have transpired so it's like
do what you do get to where you got to
get to anyway uh
her father came in
he's like hey what's going on I ain't
that much this and this and that and
then you hear a boom
what's the bone the Boom is the two Cody
finish that went into the bathroom one
of them tried to set the shotgun up on
the bathtub it fell boom into the
bathtub make causing that noise
so then he's like oh what the hell he
going there a little oh what the hell
y'all get up out of my house y'all need
to get out my house
so then a few hours later I guess the
detective started making their rounds
knocking on doors asking if they see
anybody or anything suspicious
him being a law-abiding citizen he said
yeah I think my daughter knows something
I think she knows something and this is
how everything started to unravel
um
one of my Cody we had all gotten away so
to speak
one of my co-defendants
um was from the Bay Area so he kept
trying to call a cab at two three in the
morning it was about three in the
morning now and so by this time the
detectives are in the cab because this
guy called a cab went to a a motel paid
cash got spooked went to another motel
pay cash call the cab said hey I want to
want a cab to take me to the Bay
cab driver tell him okay I guess that I
don't allegedly told him it was about
200 and he was like okay I could pay
that I could pay that in cash so that
made the police suspicious so the police
ended up pulling up in the cab posing as
a taxi driver
asking him what was going on
kept asking questions and then he
allegedly just beginning to tell what
happened from the beginning to the end
this is how my co-defense was implicated
this is how I was implicated and this is
how we all ended up doing life in prison
I ended up getting a 25 year to life
since then I ended up doing 26 years and
eight months
so during that time it was hectic you
know I learned to
um
I learned to to be quiet that's that's
where I learned to be quiet I learned to
be quiet and watch
because you know walking on to walking
in the San Quentin was was was was was
weird it was weird crazy because you see
men who look like women and then you see
men I saw men with legs with arms is as
big as my leg like my thigh leg my thumb
like these dudes are so big monster is
huge so again at that fear but that fear
also was like man I ain't going out I
ain't going out you know I'm not going
out
so I learned to be quiet and watch I
learned to do what everybody else is
learning to do how to make a knife where
to hide it what how to move how to watch
it back how to see what's going on how
to be able to recognize some stuff from
afar before it came to me or how to
maneuver around it I learned so many
different things that kept me safe in
prison I was never a victim I was never
ran off a yard I was never stabbed I was
never disciplined there's guys who come
into prison in first week two weeks
discipline tattoos are rolling up off of
the yard taking psych meds like to me
that was all different ways of escaping
but I was like I'm here now so none of
that mattered to me I was just trying to
figure out what it is I needed to do
because even though I had life in prison
I never felt like I was going to die in
prison I never felt like not one time
that I felt like I was gonna die in
prison in my mind
but looking back during the instances
when there were race riots where there
was just things just going on on the
yard between different races game fights
and you know when those bullets get the
wizard hey that that's that's something
completely different you know you hear
that that loud shotgun that not the
shotgun the the uh Big Bertha with what
we used to call her and uh that's the
one with the black gun you hear that
that's enough to shake you for a minute
but then after a while you get used to
hearing that like oh that ain't nothing
because you seeing people getting
stabbed like damn why they stabbing like
that they should have stabbed him over
there by their bathroom and they should
have broke that piece off into him and
like oh look uh they got him oh he
pissing you can see just piss just
running out the girl and like oh like
really becoming cold like
it's but that was necessary to survive
I had to feel that I had to not feel I
had to be cold because to feel something
would make me vulnerable you understand
what I'm saying and then survival you
know to survive and then to adopt you
know it's either you're gonna hunt or
you're gonna be the haunted and that's
just the way it is in there I've seen so
many things and and not just on the on
the on the side of the prisoners I've
seen the police do crooked Shady things
you know I've seen dudes you know trying
to get out of their cells because
they're not getting along with their
cell mate and then the police couple in
the mud dragging them up the stairs
graded stairs how does it stay in prison
dragging them up the stairs throwing
them into a cell telling them what you
gonna do cause I'm about to go home you
want to sleep with them cuffs I don't
even want me to take them off what you
gonna do but it's taking cups off
some crazy things I've seen happen I
haven't been in the shoes where
you know the police had come by Corcoran
shoe 93 94 police come by just they
don't like you or if they just trying to
get you to go somewhere mentally they'll
take your food they'll just throw your
tray inside slam the slam the tray stock
close what you gonna do eat that off the
floor
this is canteen they don't bring you a
canteen when they did they put it in
Brown Bags everything bust open the
chest Brown Bag soups Brown Bag cookies
Brown Bag you know so I had to learn man
I had to learn how to survive you know I
had to learn how to save my lunch take
the bread wet the towel wrap it around
the wet towel Fold It Up that's gonna
keep the bread soft because if I don't
do that it's gonna get hard in the brown
bag in a wax bag you know the little
white sandwich bags but uh learning the
man being in prison man I saw so many
different things but the things that I
saw are also the things that changed me
because to me I'm like why would I want
I don't want that
I don't want that I don't I'm not insane
right my I have all my mental bearings
I'm a little emotionally shook
because of you know my upbringing and
things that I've been through uh but as
far as
as far as uh
I believe as far as anything else man
it's like prison once you have a certain
understanding a certain maturity about
yourself like you understand that prison
is really for losers you know you go for
the first time you figure it out
uh it's unfortunate I had to spend so
much time in prison to figure it out but
if I'd only done like five or six years
even if I would have done 10 years
honestly I would have came out the same
person just this this prison
rehabilitate anyone say what that's
funny you said does prison rehabilitate
absolutely not
it takes an individual to in to to
rehabilitate themselves prison don't do
nothing prison don't do nothing but I
was you that's it
I saw a prison does and you come out
institutionalized some do
some do I thought for a while because I
was so used to getting into a shower
washing my boxes washing my socks then
washing myself up that I thought because
I heard so many other people say that
those are the things that they did when
they got out of prison for me that
wasn't my issue that was not my issue
for me my issue was walking into as if
I'm walking into a prison for the first
time I've been in so many different
prisons
it's ridiculous
um and that's because a lot of the Yards
that I went to they were either
transitioning like a lot of yards that I
was on was transitioning like Mill Creek
Corcoran those jaws was transitioning
from GP yards to S and Y yards so I was
on some of those yards for like 45 days
on another bus on to somewhere else but
uh the point that I was making is is
that the rehabilitation comes from self
like
the the what I had to learn to deal with
was uh assessing people
recognizing a threat a possible threat
it's like walking in the on the yard and
for the first time you know cleared go
to the yard you don't know who's there
you don't know what's what so you look
and you assess people so when I got out
I remember going to a Fridays
um with my ex-wife and and I noticed
these two gentlemen who you know I could
tell they was Street and then they was
just looking at me they had this look
and it could have been yeah because I'm
fresh out of prison I know I have a
different or a different look a
different vibe but that Drew caution to
me you know and I remember telling my
girl I don't know what's these guys is
on but uh
I'm gonna have to get one of them things
she was like what what one more things I
was being funny because I I don't want
to go back to jail so but I didn't
really want one of those things but I
was just trying to tell her in a way
that I was a little bothered by what was
going on and her reaction was completely
not what I thought it was her reaction
was more like ain't nobody worried about
you you need to stop tripping and that
was only that was only one incident of
several others I remember uh going
shopping at the outlet in San Diego
we went to the Nike outlet and it was
there was you know it was crowded but it
was a guy who walked past me and just
bumped me like
bumped me enough to where I turned a
little bit so I stopped I I completely
just stopped in my tracks and I was
processing like
to myself self-taught very valuable very
important because what we tell ourselves
is going to determine how we feel how we
think and what we will do so I was
telling myself oh that ain't nothing
that ain't nothing just take a deep
breath that ain't nothing he don't know
because if he knew he wouldn't have
bumped me like that he would have walked
around me but the good thing is he don't
know which means he don't see the glass
around my feet the broken glass he don't
know where I came from so that was a
testament to my change but then in the
same instance my ex-wife came up to me
it's like why are you looking like that
straighten your face and and so
to be in a relationship with someone
that you're around constantly and for
them not to understand
what I a person that's incarcerated has
been through for so many years if they
don't understand like they they can they
can cost more they can cause some some
mental and emotional harm
you know and that's the reason why
she is my ex now because she couldn't
deal with the things that I was going
through and I still have challenges I
still find challenges you know my
biggest thing right now is road rage I
used to pray like you know God let me
out I promise I'm gonna obey all the
rules and man I drive I drive I speed
you know because I don't like people
slowing me down getting in my way I'm a
defensive driver but uh road rage is my
biggest thing that's my biggest problem
right now
what's your biggest regret my biggest
regret I'm glad I just asked me that
because my biggest regret was uh not
preventing
not preventing the crime that I was
involved in and because of how to
prevented it I would have saved this
man's life and and that's kind of why I
said earlier like this guy was my hero
because I didn't have a father you know
you got convicted of murder like
everybody else absolutely did got
convicted of murder 25 years of life and
that was not your intent sorry that was
not your intention when you
get into this no absolutely not my
intention was just to be the lookout get
get that 15 bands that that was it
wasn't nobody's supposed to be there
so again this guy became my hero because
he was a father Who provided for his
family he's a father who died for his
family and I'm like man that that to me
that's what a man is supposed to do
that's what a father is supposed to do
you know so that's kind of what puts me
on the the the track that I'm on
mentally even when I being confronted or
feel like something is going on
something's wrong you know I I just
stopped and I just think like
you know why would I do that I don't
want to put myself back in the situation
I want to be that man I want to be that
father I want to be here for my children
you know when I get married again I want
to be here for my wife I want to be a
provider I want to be a protector you
know and I want to add value I'm going
to add value to this world you know if I
can't do that then how would anybody
ever know I was here
and uh now that you're out what what are
your plans what's your biggest fear now
whew my biggest fear
um
my biggest fear is is not being able to
create
Financial sources to sustain myself to
you know I want to get to a point to
where I'm making money when I'm sleep
because there's no retirement plan for
me you know I I'm I'm surpassed that so
you know I wrote a book while I was in
there uh called on GP I wrote a book
while I was in prison everybody used to
talk about Donald goines and all these
different authors and true to the game
and all this other like man if I read
one of those I might as well write a
book so that's what I did I wrote a book
you know I do music I still do my music
I write
um I dropped a couple of songs
um
let me see my first video two years ago
I just dropped a couple of songs last
month and I got a new release a new
single coming out on the fifth Cinco de
Mayo
so emotionally would you go through when
you were in prison sorry emotionally
what were you going through emotionally
because I'm sure you felt like how did I
get into this you know yeah absolutely
like
for a long time I wondered if it was
real like sorry somebody playing a joke
on me
like no seriously somebody playing a
joke with me it's gonna all be over
they're gonna come and pop the door be
like hey come here it's over we just Dad
you want to experiment wanted to see how
you were gonna take it and take a bad
dream a bad dream that's exactly what I
thought it was and like I said um
you know being in prison for so long and
uh
being detached I lost my mom uh in 2005
and my mom was my backbone she was my
main source of support she was always
there for me
um visits even when I told her not to
come she'd come anyway you know she
started to get ill you know um dialysis
kidney failure and um
yeah so when my mom passed it was like I
was alone like nobody I can't there was
nobody I can call on to just hey I need
a hundred dollars to save my life I
couldn't count on nobody couldn't count
on nobody didn't have wasn't in contact
with my father
um so emotionally I felt like I felt
like I didn't have nobody but myself so
I was up against it it was like a
a good day a bad day a good day a bad
day and that's why I was so bitter for a
long time while I was in prison because
I felt like everything that was going on
around me was everybody else's fault you
know I felt like I ain't the one who
pulled the trigger so why am I doing all
these years in jail you know you kill
her I'm not
but I'm responsible yeah you understand
what I'm saying just get involved in
some I'm responsible because I could
have prevented it so yeah so I got to
eat that like everybody else had to eat
it you know I have to take it for what
it is
so I remember uh in another part of the
the whole emotional thing right it's
like like I was saying it's like my mom
was my biggest supporter so you know
after not having any contact with anyone
it's like sitting in the cell waiting
waiting for count to clear just so I can
get some dinner and maybe get a phone
call or some day room so during the
count time you know either right before
or right after using the seals that
they'll come around you hit the doors
boom boom 180 you hear the doors boom
boom you can hear him he's in a section
you hear this you can hear the keys
attention sounds like sound like Jingle
Bells you can hear the keys and then
boom boom Carson section that's
C-section that's the section I'm in you
know just just remembering like hearing
those keys and hearing them call names
I'm like oh I want something even though
I don't know nobody in the world that's
gonna write me who's gonna write me
every now and then you'll get that
letter and it's like Christmas it's like
man you bust that thing open the first
thing you used to do though look on the
back and see if it was a stamp I don't
know how they do it now I've been out
five years but they used to put this
snap on the back and you can just get it
and feel it and tell if there's some
pictures in there if you didn't feel no
pictures you look at the back and be
like man I wanna have some money on
there if somebody send me some money you
know because you start to feel like the
world is surreal like you start to feel
I started to feel like the only thing
that existed was me in that prison in
that world of chaos on disorganized
chaos because that's how the police ran
it disorganized chaos you know a bunch
is fake politics a bunch of fake
everything things that man I'm from
Seaside California man I I grew up
around everybody you know and then you
get into an environment where people
telling you they can't talk to you they
can't sit with you they can't play cards
with you they can't eat with you they
can't accept nothing from you if it's
not uh sealed if it's not brand new it's
like wow really crazy what do you think
the solution is for
guys in your situation that grew up in
maybe a tough neighborhood didn't have
their dad in their life
what I mean is there a solution in your
mind honestly
there is or something that can help the
absolutely there is so
about
I believe it was about 2012.
a guy told me hey man you should read a
book
I was like what's the name of the book
he said oh it's called Uh a man's search
for meaning by Victor Franco
so I read that book and that that book
was deep you know
um in that book it was a guy who ended
up going to uh the Jewish Camp I believe
it was Auschwitz or something like that
but anyway he ended up going to one of
those one of those camps and um he had
lost his wife
and he said in order he was saying that
in order for him to
um deal with losing his wife is by
understanding that he would rather
suffer that pain than for him to die and
know that she would suffer that pain
from losing him I was like that's D so I
started to begin to learn about
perception perspective you know looking
outside of the box and to me that's what
actually looking outside of the box is
is being able to broaden your perception
right to take your perception and to
take everybody else's perception in the
room that makes you the most valuable
yet the most dangerous person in the
room
because you can understand from
everybody's angle you understand what
I'm saying so that book was a good book
the next book was um Seven Habits of
Highly Effective People I've probably
read Maybe
half of that book before the guy that
let me read the book was going home and
he took the book with him and I was a
little upset I was like you're going
home what you need to book for
but when I read the book
looking at the stories that changed the
perception for instance the guy
he was driving a car just to give a
brief example about perception he was
driving a car nice Little Red Corvette
let's say and he see this kid this kid
is just throwing rocks at these cars as
they go by so he tells himself he said
I'm gonna go slow and if this little kid
throws a rock in my car I'm gonna get
out and I'm gonna whip his ass right so
he goes slow he doesn't stop the kid
doesn't do nothing the kid is just
looking kid got his hands up he keeps
driving by the kid picks up a ride boom
throws it at his car boom puts it didn't
inside his car he gets out looks he sees
his den he said hey what's the wrong
with you what the hell is wrong with you
so before he could finish chastising the
kids the kid throws his hands up he says
I'm sorry mister I'm sorry but I've been
out here for hours and my my brother's
in the wheelchair he fell over in the
ditch and he's too heavy for me to pick
him up so the man never changed the dent
never fixed the dent in this door
because he always wanted to be reminded
of perception that sometimes it's not
what we see sometimes we just have to
stop and ask and see it from somebody
else's point of view and that was just
one of them so that is what started to
change my life perception I started to
see things the way that other people saw
him and not just the way I thought they
were you know I used to kick Sally's out
just for snoring I used to kick Sally's
out if their blanket was hanging down
the front of the bed or the back of the
bed I used to kick them by myself I used
to kicking my community you gotta go fam
this is what it is you got to get up out
of here I had some good sellers you know
but again it was the perception that
changed my life so if someone wanted to
change and when we spoke about
Rehabilitation you asked me this prison
rehability prison does not rehabilitate
I don't care how many programs they
offer how much this or that they offer
it does not it's the individual it takes
the individual to rehabilitate
themselves and the best thing that I
could ever advise someone to do
especially if you're a lifer and you're
going to the board
think about it like this when you're
going to that boardroom they're not
going to ask you questions that you
don't already know
I went to the boardroom and I seen so
many
um
I think they were 114 D's confidential
kites like I seen so many I was like
they know about stuff that I was like
what the hell crazy but yeah there's
always an inside man that's just the way
it is so you got to leave the crap alone
leave all that crap alone Be you because
if you're gonna get into some drama
you're gonna get into some drama whether
you're riding by yourself or whether
you're riding with 100 other people so
be yourself do your thing do your time
and and and think about perception so
when you're going to that boardroom what
they want to hear is you doing an
autopsy on your body on the old person
that you were and if you can cut that
body open and talk about the things that
you did Growing Up the things that
happened to you you know when you're
talking about lifestyle factors life
history factors those are the things
that they're talking about you know what
are the things that happen to you at a
young age that you could not change and
what are the things that you chose to do
when you started to get older that you
decided to do on your own
and then be able to understand why you
did them you know hurt people hurt
people that's why I committed the crime
I committed because I didn't care about
how nobody else is feeling
somebody stole my bike I'm gonna steal
some bikes you know I don't have no
money to get it ain't nobody trying to
give it to me so I'm gonna go steal it
I'm gonna go take it
you know all just
false life False Image false Pride
looking at people
like oh that's cool I'm gonna emulate
that that's what I'm gonna be I was a
thousand different people man I was a
thousand different people
and then I decided like one day like man
you know with the perception that I
learned it then I gained
it's like man what was it worth you know
my mom died while I was in prison I
didn't get to go to her funeral
you know I lost a little brother two
nephews while I was in prison I didn't
get to go to the funeral
you know
it is what it is when is it gonna stop
it's gonna stop now what do you think
the most important thing you learned in
all of this
the most important thing that I learned
in all this is that
material things mean absolutely nothing
it's the memories
that we make are the things that are
going to sustain us when we take off on
our breath in my opinion
hmm
all right Eugene yes very interesting
talk thank you so much absolutely
wish you lots of luck now that you're
out I appreciate you and y'all can check
me out at why be loyal
check me out check out my music I'm
dropping a new CD a new single called
pain on Cinco de Mayo five five twenty
twenty three all right thank you very
much yes sir